ja und die welt sie will nun natürlich
wissen wer genau hat das grauen von
butscher zu verantworten wer hat
hunderte wehrlose menschen hingerichtet
max kiebel und julian röcke sind den
tätern auf der spur
[Musik]
der die westliche staatengemeinschaft
sie konnte die menschen von butscher
nicht vor ihren mördern retten konnte
sie nicht schützen vor diesen russischen
soldaten die dort wehrlose zivilisten
ermordet haben julian das wichtigste ist
jetzt in so einer phase aber natürlich
die verantwortlichen aufzuspüren
informationen zusammenzutragen die dazu
führen dass die mörder am ende überführt
werden können und da gibt es eine erste
heiße spur julian denn das ukrainische
geheimdienstministerium
verteidigungsministerium die haben eine
liste veröffentlicht von einer einheit
die im mittelpunkt dieses
kriegsverbrechen stehen könnte julian
wir schauen direkt drauf denn das hier
das ist also die liste der soldaten der
64 motorisierten schützen brigade die
bis zuletzt in butter stationiert waren
wir ganz genau wir wissen heute dass
verschiedene einheiten über verschiedene
zeiten in butter waren aber diese
einheit hier wurde identifiziert als die
die in den letzten drei wochen dort das
sagen hatte und die einheit und das ist
das interessante die spezielle
truppenteile auch am äußeren zu sehende
truppenteile in sich hatten nämlich
ethnische minderheiten aus russland und
diese wurden von verschiedenen zeugen
gesehen haben wie ihre liebsten ihre
verwandten erschossen wurden
identifiziert
und aus diesem grunde oder müssen also
das passt zusammen mit ukrainischen
geheimdienst erkenntnissen dass genau
diese einheiten nämlich auch dort war in
der stadt zu der zeit diese liste die
wir hier vorhaben ich spiele noch mal ab
und zu grafik hat sie aufbereitet die
umfasst rund 1000 soldaten junge
soldaten ältere soldaten alle
dienstgrade und was interessant ist die
ukraine die haben hier direkt die
passdaten mit veröffentlicht manchmal
geht das mal hier das ist diese spalte
warum haben sie das gemacht na ja wenn
einer dieser soldaten in den nächsten
jahren vor hat ins ausland zu reisen
dann ist denkbar dass er dort direkt an
der grenzkontrolle festgenommen werden
könnte wenn es denn eines tages
hoffentlich zu einem strafprozess kommt
und die späteren ali mörder ausputzer
sich verantworten müssen das hier dieser
mann der könnte im mittelpunkt dieser
späteren verhandlungen dieser späteren
aufarbeitung stehen denn das hier das
ist der offizier der designer
kommandiert hat und der womöglich ja das
ganze befehligt hat oder zumindest nicht
gestoppt hat ja genau wie die vielen 16
ist der motorisierte schützende gerade
ist eine relativ große bringer gegangen
sind allein da waren 1000 namen drauf
wie man nicht alles in butter aber ich
glaube den ukrainer ist es wichtig
dieses naming and gaming zu betreiben
also ganz klar zu machen wir wissen wer
ihr seid und wir wissen dass er hier war
wie gesagt die zeugen die wir die wir
auch mit uns gesprochen haben haben eben
gesagt so was wie ja das waren
verschiedene leute dort einige sahen
europäisch aus andere sein und dann hieß
es kasachisch aus aber wir haben noch
mal nachgefragt haben noch mal
nachgeforscht und für diese ukrainer
dort aus diesen dörflichen gegenden auch
ältere für ältere frau und teilweise ist
alles was sozusagen nicht im
europäischen entspricht und nicht dem da
sage ich mal dem dem kaukasischen
entspricht so aus dieser aus
tschetschenien dagestan gegend was also
anders aussieht ist für die kasachstan
wir haben aber danach gefragt und es
gibt auch bei blizzard einem
belarussischen oppositions sender eine
weitere zeugenaussage wo leute gesagt
haben dem anschein nach kamen einige der
mörder aus grazien aus der autonomen
region pro jahr ziehen im osten
russlands beraten die wie wir wissen
auch in dieser einheit hier der 64
mechanisierten brigade teetisch machen
es gibt ein foto dieser einheit dass man
es einmal sieht von was sprechen wir
hier eigentlich wir wissen nicht ob
diese menschen auf diesem foto
kriegsverbrechen begangen haben dass es
ganz klar aber diese menschen diese
soldaten sind teil der einheit die hier
im mittelpunkt steht und du sagst es
eben optisch unterscheiden sie sich heid
vom blauäugigen blonden klassischen
russischen soldaten denn sie gehören
einer ethnischen minderheit an aus
russland und du hast es gesagt die
beweiskette wir schauen auf die karte
ich stopp ist ganz kurz einmal am anfang
denn diese einheit sie kommt vom anderen
ende der erde kann man fast sagen das
ist richtig die einheit kommt von 8000
kilometer weiter östlich der ukrainer
dort wurde sie mobilisiert im januar im
rahmen der kriegsvorbereitung und ich
finde es noch mal ganz wichtig zu sagen
wir sehen hier viele baten die einheit
bestand nicht nur aus bewahrten aber
auch in russland gibt es sagen wir mal
wenn es an rassismus aber ethnischen
differenzen das heißt wir haben fotos
aus dieser einheit von menschen die aus
dem jemand aus moskau die sich in
gruppen fotografien und wir haben fotos
aus dieser einheit menschen die aussehen
wie jemand aus pro jahr ziehen die sich
in gruppen fotografieren mischen sich
sein sage ich mal weniger weniger oft
als als man es vielleicht vermuten
könnte und diese einheit wurde und wir
sehen uns jetzt hier mitte januar
mobilisiert mittel mobilisiert und immer
wieder fotografiert und gefilmt auf
ihrem weg in die ukraine und zwar nicht
nur in die ukraine sondern bewusst dass
geister sehen genau in die region
nördlich von kiew am 7 dort genau zu der
zeit übrigens also einen tag bevor bevor
dieses massaker stattgefunden hat genau
dort gefilmt an dem ort wo auch diese
verbrechen stattgefunden das hier ist
ganz wichtig denn das hier das verortet
diese einheit am tatort das hier ist
nicht ukrainische informationen
ukrainische geheimdienst informationen
sondern dass hier sind fotos die eben
und videos die in den vergangenen acht
wochen zwölf wochen entstanden sind wo
eben diese einheit dokumentiert worden
ist wie sie quer durch russland gefahren
ist diese diese videos julian aus denen
diese diese fotos die wir hier gezogen
haben kommen wie normal ist dass das oft
tik tok und anderen plattformen diese
züge gefilmt wurden und jetzt womöglich
ja als beweisstücke gelten können ja ich
finde es auch diesen mix total spannend
wir haben hier einmal die leute die ins
elfi von sich machen weil sie sich
fotografieren lassen vor ihrer vor ihrer
kaserne dann haben wir eben von
russischen passanten diese ganzen videos
und fotos wir haben da schon im januar
besprochen das war sehr ja also man kann
halt eine riesige armee von 200.000 mann
nicht heimlich bewegen durch ein
riesiges land wenn immer wieder gefilmt
und fotografiert und was ich wichtig
findet das letzte foto man sieht ja
vielleicht diesen stern in der ecke das
ist nicht von passanten das ist nicht
von irgendwelchen zeugen gemacht worden
das ist von der russischen armee selbst
veröffentlicht worden die russische
armee die also stolz darauf war dass
diese einheit nördlich von kiew aktiva
und versucht hat mittlerweile wurde
dementiert versucht hat die ukrainische
hauptstadt dort zu erobern
was glaubst du wie wie kann sowas jetzt
weiter gehen welche weiteren bruchstücke
braucht man und am ende einzelne
soldaten womöglich anklagen zu können
was wird dafür noch gebraucht du hast
die zeugenaussagen zb an gesprochen wie
wichtig ist das jetzt ja also mir
persönlich sind bisher vier
zeugenaussagen bekannt von vier
überlebenden die gesagt haben dass diese
menschen dort waren zusammen mit den
informationen der russischen armee den
frei verfügbaren informationen
informationen des ukrainischen
geheimdienstes ergibt sich hier eine
beweiskette die in eine bestimmte
richtung führt ich persönlich halte es
für unwahrscheinlich dass am ende
einzelne soldaten dort auf der
anklagebank sitzen aber natürlich muss
man sehen wer hat die verantwortung
dafür und zwar die militärische
verantwortung in der kommandokette wir
haben vorhin den herren gesehen der die
einheit anführt das ist dieser herr hier
herum uhr big kaufen aber natürlich auch
die politische verantwortung und da sind
wir im kreml da sind wir im programm im
russischen verteidigungsministerium bei
herrn schoigu und natürlich im kreml bei
herrn putin die politik zu verantworten
haben was die kürzlichen soldaten hier
begangen haben wir werden natürlich
weiter diese aufarbeitung genau
begleiten und genau hinschauen und auch
dokumentieren bei uns wollen jetzt aber
noch einmal ein stück weit in die
zukunft schauen nämlich das was sich
momentan abspielt in der ukraine und
besser gesagt außerhalb noch der ukraine
denn du hast dieses video hier
mitgemacht wir sehen wieder genauso ein
video von panzern auf einem zug warum
ist dieses video wichtig wären ja dieses
video erinnert uns an die hunderten
videos von sich bewegenden panzer nach
westen bewegen den panzern die wir im
januar und februar gesehen haben wo
damals noch alle gehofft haben naja
vielleicht sind das nur manöver oder die
verleger nur aus spaß oder wie auch
immer am ende war's kriegsvorbereitung
und dieses video ist nicht aus dem
januar sondern augen aus dem februar
sondern es ist von gestern es ist also
von anfang märz und wir sehen dass hier
neue russische panzer unterwegs sind aus
richtung moskau und recht grellen ja das
ist in der nähe der ukraine und wir
glauben und nicht nur wir sondern die
von die grössten experten vom team von
einer investigativ plattform glauben
dass diese panzer bewegungen die wir
nicht nur in moskau sehen sondern auch
in jekaterinburg sehen mit einer
mobilisierung von 60.000 neuen
russischen soldaten zusammenhängt die
die verluste den ukrainer in den ruß
hinzugefügt haben ausgleichen sollen und
für eine neue offensive eine zweite
welle im osten der ukraine bereit stehen
sollen dass wir vielleicht noch mal
sagen also in den letzten tagen da haben
wir das hier vor allem beobachtet
nämlich den abzug den rückzug der
russischen truppen aus der region kirow
und auch aus cerny ich das mal ein und
aus sumy all diese gebiete waren noch
vor einer woche teils komplett besetzt
teilweise besetzt hier sind alle
russischen truppen raus aber wir sehen
eben im osten der ukraine überhaupt kein
ende der offensive im gegenteil auch der
ukrainische generalstab hat heute gesagt
wir haben weitere gebiete verloren die
russen rücken attraktiv internets und
und lugansk weiter vor wo sind gerade
die stärksten vorstöße wenn du das ein
zeichen ist ja sowohl auf welche realen
schaut man aus ukrainischer sicht mit
größter sorge wir können einmal zeigen
hier haben wir aktiv die großstadt die
weiterhin gehalten wird von der ukraine
wir sehen aber einen russischen vorstoß
in diese richtung und vielleicht kann
ich ein mal kurz eine andere farbe haben
ausrief nach süden geht der vorstoß und
versucht eben dort die ukrainische
truppen die hier nicht erst seit kurzem
sondern seit 2014 die front verteidigen
gegen die sogenannten separatisten
damals und mittlerweile gegen starke
russisch verbände die sollen eingekreist
werden und wenn die eingekreist werden
dann wäre das ein super gau und dann
wäre auch der sieg von katja 1 1 1 sieg
aber eben leider nicht dass das ende der
schlacht und kein sieg des krieges weil
man hätte dann sozusagen hier den kessel
von donezk oder wie auch immer man ihn
nennen will aber der würde es eben den
ukrainischen truppen unmöglich machen
sich selbst zurückzuziehen und auf der
anderen seite nachschub in irgendeiner
form dort rein zu bekommen das wäre wie
du sagst du schlimmste anzunehmende
situationen für die ukrainische truppen
dort letzte frage was erleben wir hier
unten im süden wir haben oft und viel
über besser gesprochen die möglichkeit
einer amphibischen landung daneben der
vorstoß in richtung mikolaiski ist
aktuell der stand aktuell haben wir hier
eher ein herr in sich entwickelnden
sitzt krieg sage ich mal wir hatten
zuerst den russischen vorstoß der wie du
bist gesagt dass bis nördlich von mücke
life ging der versucht hat und das auch
zu erreichen
das hat er nicht geschafft wir hatten an
eine ukrainische gegenoffensive letzte
woche die bis fast nach herr sonnen dass
es etwa hier passt noch herr sohn
vorgedrungen ist mittlerweile sehen wir
aber auch wieder russische kleinere
vorstöße und die ukraine die vororte von
kassen wieder verloren haben sind also
ein hin und her und wir sehen russen
russischen truppen die versuchen sich
hier einzugraben zu verfestigen und
parallel und das ist wirklich
alarmierend sehen wir dass russland hier
wie soll ich sagen soldo staatliche
strukturen aufbaut nenne ich eine
volksrepublik person aus rufen möchte
das haben wir schon vor dem krieg
berichtet da scheint es jetzt erste
bemühungen zu geben hier ukrainische
marionetten und lag 1 zu finden die also
dieses gebiet zu einer neuen
volksrepublik wie die beiden
volksrepublik hier im osten ausrufen
werden und damit der ukraine ein stück
weit ja für immer ihr eigenes land
wegnehmen würden ihre eigene region
wegnehmen würden julian vielen dank für
deine analyse wir haben es gehört ein
dramatisches und ständig sich
veränderndes schlachtfeld und auf der
anderen seite eben diese ermittlungen
gegen die mutmaßlichen mörder die wir
natürlich hier in unserem lagebild
weiter genau beobachten werden jetzt
geht sie aber erstmal weiter mit bild
live